For a third day, wildfires sweeping
through parts of Los Angeles, lock
after block, there is nothing
but ash.
Breaking news where US President
Donald Trump assigned tariffs
on America's top trading partners.
These supply chains will have a
profound impact on inflation,
on the well-being of US households.
We are seeing very significant
demand for maven both
in and outside of America.
Tonight, I can report to the world
that these strikes were a
spectacular military
success.
More than a summer's worth of rain
fell in a matter of hours,
triggering unprecedented flash
flooding.
After Russia launched another major
overnight attack on that country's
energy infrastructure.
China's largest military
display.
Here, showcase Apollo.
The government shutdown stretches
into a fresh new week.
And the path forward is unclear.
The sound of the alarm that Silicon
Valley and the West have lost
their way.
You're in favor of this world order.
What have you built that works?
We are in a software-defined world,
and the nation that leads software
is the USA.